you should always drink that much water
yeah what I don't rape it that's what
you have bad skin my current relation
with the water is that I love playing in
it I love the way it looks do I put it
inside me no I should be drinking more
water I'm trying much more easy well
good for you I know but it doesn't
matter doesn't I don't like it he's like
garbage I mean it doesn't taste like
garbage but it like doesn't taste good
drinking water is like one of the most
basic things you can do and I'm bad at
it it's like being bad at breathing
which I also am because I have asthma
there are multiple days that go by where
I'm confident I don't drink any water so
for 30 days I'm gonna try and drink
eight glasses of water a day which
sounds really easy but I know it's not
going to be the eight 8-ounce glasses
rule it's just easy for people to
remember I am a little skeptical about
it but there must be something about it
I'm hoping that my mood will be nice and
even maybe I won't eat as much I'm
excited to have that like Halle Berry
skin where I look twelve but I'm really
70 I think she gets it from Water Week
one was actually I feel almost the
easiest week so this is my third out of
four glasses from the day I'm doing
pretty good
I feel like but I was really committed
and devoted and I was like waiting for
like my skin to start glowing and I was
waiting all right hold up honestly a lot
happened over the month we didn't really
understand why all these changes were
taking place so we decided to bring in a
water expert who could actually tell us
why things are happening to our body and
whether it was even related to water
these waters not like a miracle elixir
right I'm here with Albert Matheny do
you just walk around looking this fit
all the time my job I'm exercise
physiologist and registered dietician oh
you're like a billboard for yourself
brilliant how much water should people
really drink I mean some days I'm like
oh god I have to I have to do this for a
month I kind of have to like drink all
this water there's such a simple thing
it's actually really hard to do
and I don't think that anyone is getting
the right amount of water I think we
also just like have IVs that we walk
around with you just pick up for the
average person 64 ounces enough not to
cause problems so it's not a bar that I
would shoot for you should go above that
oh that's a more water oh I failed this
was so hard and it is lower I would say
anywhere between eight and if you're
like an active larger person outside a
lot especially if you like work outside
you can easily be double that like no
questions 15 officers oh yeah I wasn't
prepared for that information what are
the health benefits of water I mood to
be improved I like spring out of bed and
I wake right up it was shocking I'm a
fairly pleasant person when like men
were trying it like I didn't really get
as annoyed I was more just like whatever
but he's definitely shot up my energy
I'm like my happiness waking up was a
lot easier and also falling asleep with
a lot easier it's really surprising how
much drinking some water can make you
feel better
next time you're like man I need a
coffee a lot of times if you just drink
some water you're gonna feel more
energized if I didn't drink any water at
all would I be like sixteen by the time
I'm 30 I will say one of the happy side
effects is I've been having really great
skin days so I haven't been wearing
makeup at all so I've been just going
fresh-faced didn't really feel like I
needed it I felt like my skin was
looking good but like I just felt good
when I was looking in the mirror in the
morning I did feel I looked a little
brighter
youthful basically water helps hydrate
all your tissues and skins like your
Ardis organ if you're staying hydrated
your skin should have like nice
elasticity and some like give to it and
if you're really gadget it's gonna be
like tighter and like more prone to
being dry water in general should be
helpful for your skin to be like supple
feel like chronically dehydrated the
chances of your lips being chapped are
pretty high so how would I know if I'm
chronically dehydrated
I've been drinking a lot today and I'm
still thirsty I notice I'm more thirsty
if I don't drink enough it's difficult I
try basically any time you feel thirsty
I mean you're already kind of died
we were like drinking before that I
always used to get hey I gotta have one
cocktail I'd be hungover this allowed
you to drink more oh my god and I was
fine when that with my friends last
night we drank a lot with the amount
that we drank I anticipated today being
like awful and like a useless day and I
feel 100% okay but I feel fine
like I wouldn't even know that I drank
like I won't give up my usual time I'm
tired but like I'm not hurting the way
that I have in the past and that's
bonkers to me staying hydrated helps you
I kind of regulate or just know when
you're actually hungry risk when you're
just thirsty hey I don't want to have
eight drinks like I usually do because I
really wanted to have four and I just
end up having eight cuz that happens a
lot
episode yeah the water alternation
between drinks is nice so you drink like
what you're supposed to drink and water
I drink all our food how much time do
you spend in bathroom I have to pee so
bad right now I can't even function I
literally just went to the bathroom like
thirty minutes ago or an hour ago
I feel like I have to go again it's like
you're just going revolving door between
two you in the bathroom three glasses of
water in I really have to pee I have to
pee
this is so much pain I hate using public
restrooms and this water challenge has
created this urgency for me to pee I
imagine this is what it's like to be
pregnant
trying to find a bathroom I've gone just
three separate places they don't have
public restrooms because in cities they
don't do that
maybe time changed the timing of
consumption guys have bigger bladders
here I found that when I was drinking a
lot of water I was having like two three
bowel movements a day
is that like mine or am I just not
pooping usually enough I just fed me
like 50% of my time and
it's my humble pen so just sliding right
out so it seems like a hydration helps
with everything the water is helping
things run smoother through my system
it helped me have regular PMS and that
really saved my butt hole it's gonna
make you go the bathroom more because
you think about how you don't have
enough water it's me really compact and
dry like inside of you and take a long
time to get out but if you have water
it's a much more fluid process Oh rats
you just gave like a free constipation
remedy yes no II don't that's like a
massive benefit is just moving stuff
through your system drinking a
substantial amount of water can you lose
weight I didn't notice that I was
drinking the water so that I wasn't
grabbing food and I was more concerned
about having the water
oh I'm drinking this water so I guess I
don't need to put all that trash in my
body I've been waitin myself and he did
like waver first week I lost 4 pounds so
I was actually expecting to be like this
is gonna keep going just with water but
no it evened out but still in the end I
had lost 6 pounds
indirectly you're allowing your body to
pass more waste so maybe you're backed
up or something someone may be like wow
I just lost 4 pounds and they hadn't
gone to the bathroom for a number of
days it might help you better understand
when you're actually hungry and that
might help you lose weight cause you
you're not overeating yeah healthy
change like that a lot of times it makes
me more self-aware and more in tune to
the body if you're properly hydrated
you're not gonna get false hunger cues
about oh I feel thirsty which is really
a similar feeling to like when you feel
hungry is that normal to like feel so
loved it I am dealing with
water babies a little sponges that come
in the pills and you put them in the
water and then it just like turns into
like a huge massive thing I just like
expanded because it's so tight bearable
I'd to unzip the waist of my skirt a
little bit because I couldn't like I
couldn't breathe that usually plays a
role with like how much salt you're also
consuming because your body's gonna hold
on to the water if your salt consumption
is pretty high because like we talked
about you're trying to maintain this
balance of like salt water ratio so if
you're eating a pretty high salt diet
then your body's gonna retain a lot of
water well I get dependent on drinking
all of this water I was like oh I have
to drink the water but then I changed my
tune just came from my dance lesson and
I've got my water bottle here I had to
go to a dance weekend and I and I would
certainly drink a lot of water because I
was dancing a lot I was so thirsty
throughout class and usually I wouldn't
even bring water so I guess I'm getting
addicted to water I think in a good way
you might feel like wow this is making
you feel better I have more energy or
I'm not feeling this hungry all the time
it keeps you in homeostasis and wants to
even things out so if you're chronically
dehydrated it can kind of adjust to it
so if you're giving it more water and
you're feeling better then yeah I think
so so well become a very positive way I
know water is important when that guy
was so buff and like he was like yeah a
lot of importance like you know it's
true the National Academies of Sciences
engineering and medicine said the
adequate daily fluid intake is eleven
point five cups of fluids a day for
women I feel like my skin just felt like
really lustrous like I felt like my like
abs and muscles just in general like I
could feel them and they felt a little
tighter and so I felt better I'm glad
that I tested it to see that okay this
is really the outcome and now I won't
feel so guilty when I'm not when I have
like a really shitty day and all I drink
is Diet Coke all day there's no point
and like being stressed out about
consuming water
you remember needing to drink that much
it's very hard and I still think
very hard yes there wasn't too much
difference in my skin before and after
but I think I'm gonna keep doing this
and maybe in a few months I will see a
bit of a difference well if I want to
recommend this to a friend you need to
do it with a positive mindset I mean it
could help you lose weight but it's not
the reason to do it it might make you
just feel good I can't believe really
like there is a little bit of a change
here Wow my skin does look like do er
yeah I'm really happy I did the
challenge literally it's just been good
to me
so kind of keep doing it drink water
people just drink some goddamn water
[Music]